hommage et les réactions continuent
d'affluer à l' annonce de décès de
claude béland l'ancien président du
mouvement desjardins avec moi en studio
à jean martin aussant si un député
péquiste ancien chef d'option nationale
entre autres économistes de bonjour
monsieur assange ou donc vous vous avez
dirigé le chantier d'économie sociale de
2015 à 2018 si ma mémoire est bonne donc
un chantier qui avait été fondée en 96
dans la foulée du sommet de l'économie
de l'emploi qu'avait président et claude
béland donc ce chantier c'est un autre
de ces legs
c'est un autre de ces legs en fait
auquel ils contribuent fortement et
monsieur béland avait même fait en sorte
à travers des jardins que le chantier
son premier lieu physique donc a été
complètement fondamentale en fait dans
le succès à venir du chantier de
l'économie sociale donc alors
concrètement qu'est ce que c'est c'est
eh on parle beaucoup dans son
implication dans le mouvement coopératif
desjardins alors là vous dites que
desjardins était très impliqué aussi
dans ce chantier là mais desjardins est
un phare de l'économie sociale au québec
c'est une cliente coopérative financière
au monde
et puisque ça fait c'est en appuyant
chantier en fait monsieur béland a
permis de faire des petits dans tous les
secteurs d'économie parce que l'économie
sociale c'est pas un secteur économique
c'est un mode de développement qui
s'applique à tous les secteurs sous
forme coopérative ou optionnelles et
c'était en droite ligne avec les valeurs
de monsieur béland puis les deux grands
enjeux de l'humanité en ce moment c'est
assez reconnu c'est les inégalités de
richesses et les dommages
environnementaux et l'économie sociale
est une bonne partie de la réponse à ces
deux choses là puis monsieur béland
lui-même d'ailleurs s'est impliqué dans
l'est dans les deux champs très
activement et vous lui avaient rendu
hommage
c'était un honneur a fait de pouvoir
endommager monsieur béland parce que
c'est un fondateur à plusieurs égards
donc ici quand je le disais évidemment
pour le mouvement coopératif c'est un
jeu indéniable mais s'était piqué aussi
sur le plan de la démocratie le système
électoral il s'est impliqué en
environnement au jour de la terre il
s'est impliqué aussi dans plein d'autres
domaines de littératie financière c'est
très important avec le medac qui fait
des avancées aussi pour les petits
épargnants
donc c'était un géant dans tous les sens
du terme oui et c'était vraiment mettre
la riche est l'argent les finances au
service de la population
oui tout à fait en fait l'intérêt
collectif avant l'intérêt individuel
tout le temps ça fait de lui un grand
homme puis une chose qui était frappante
quand on le côtoyait c'est sa bonté
c'était un homme gentil un homme
pacifique
son sourire était toujours accroché au
visage était presque hypnotiser en fait
discuter avec lui tellement c'était à
peine
donc c'est aussi ça va manquer beaucoup
c'est une grande perte mais vous l'avez
côtoyé donc beaucoup surtout au chantier
de l'économie sociale
pas autant que j'aurais voulu et c'est
surtout quand ces gens-là kit qu'on se
dit qu'on a dû en profiter plus et avoir
plus de temps avec eux y apprendre plus
deux mais j'ai eu la chance de le
côtoyer déjà j'en suis reconnaissant
parce qu'il ratisse large l'avenir du
québec lui tenait à coeur c'est battra
également la réforme on en a parlé un
petit peu plus tôt avec d'autres invités
la réforme du mode de scrutin
et ça c'était vraiment une bataille
qu'il menait au cours des dernières
années mais c'était tout naturel pour
lui de se dire que quand la répartition
des sièges au parlement ne correspond
pas du tout au vote populaire il ya
quelque chose qui cloche
donc encore une fois c'est une question
de justice pour lui je pense et d'équité
et de fait de refléter la volonté de la
population avec une meilleure
répartition des sièges c'était un combat
important pour lui oui en fait c'est un
peu comme avec l'économie au sein de la
population le mode de scrutin où la
réforme du mode de scrutin justement
pour que chaque vote compte et ne pas
laisser justement cet enjeu là entre les
mains des partis politiques aussi le
fait que dans certaines régions du
québec avec le système actuel un vote
peut ne pas compter quand on comptait
donné d'avancé appartient aux questions
quels qu'ils soient ça vaut pas la peine
d'aller voter alors qu'une
proportionnelle ou au moins un peu de
proportionnalité ferait que je ferai en
sorte que chaque vote plus cotés ou
convives on parle
bon alors les hommages sont nombreuses
ce mouvement coopératif pour lequel il a
il s'est battu il a travaillé à jouer un
rôle d'importance dans le développement
de l'économie au québec pour les régions
aussi très longtemps pour les régions et
le mouvement desjardins et les caisses
populaires en fait on était très
important pour le développement
économique des régions puis monsieur
béland aussi voulait faire en sorte que
le mouvement coopératif soit vue comme
un outil financier aussi efficace que
les banques traditionnelles
il voulait que l'économie sociale soit
vu par les jeunes générations montantes
comme une option valable
puis je pense qu'il a lui-même prouver
que celle l'était desjardins devenu
géant mondial en étant de coopérative
donc je pense que contribuer à réveiller
des générations qui vont suivre et à
faire en sorte que le québec soit plus
prospérer aucun doute at il donc un
grand homme un grand merci beaucoup
monsieur au savoir-être avec no mercy